[Music]
[Applause]
mike florio has a new book a bestseller
it's called playmakers how the nfl
really works and doesn't now available
online wherever books are sold and uh
it's also available books on tape my
nephew uh listened to it loved it uh
mike joins us now mike the number one
story leading up to the draft is what
well i think it's weather to what extent
quarterbacks are going to be overdrafted
we had fewer available
in free agency and trades for the teams
out there that are desperate there are
some teams like the panthers that can't
convince any veteran quarterbacks to
come play for them so the only way to do
it is involuntarily with the sixth
overall pick i love the fact that three
of the teams that tried to get to sean
watson and obviously didn't in the same
division panthers falcons saints saints
have two picks between 15 and 20 that
they could package to try to cut the
line in front of the panthers at six the
falcons at eight and you hear for months
this quarterback class isn't very good
it doesn't matter because teams always
need quarterbacks and this is one way to
get them and because it's not as
expensive as it used to be
you can roll the dice if it works great
if it doesn't you'll be back in position
to draft another one soon enough so
whether or not teams take quarterbacks
who are maybe marginal prospects over
great maybe edge rushers or other
players that's what's going to fascinate
me and quarterbacks are always the story
in the nfl give me the team though that
they could change the entire first round
of the draft
well i think a team that would
decide to
obviously trade down a team in the top
five that has multiple picks and is
looking for like the giants i keep
looking at the giants at five they've
got some heavy lifting to do the best
giants teams of the past 20 years were
teams that had great offensive lines and
defensive lines
and the failure of dave gettleman the
former gm to develop the offensive line
is the biggest reason why he's the
former gm of the giants so you got joe
shane in there now who's sitting there
at five and i mentioned earlier the
saints could try to trade up they could
keep sliding back stockpiling more
lottery tickets that's what these are
they're unscratched lottery tickets one
of the points i make in playmakers and
the more tickets you get the more you
scratch the greater the chance you're
going to get some winners so
the team that can shake up the draft the
most is the team that finds the
opportunity to trade down and get the
most lottery tickets and then three four
years from now we say hey boy they had a
hell of a draft back in 2022 when we're
focused on the 2025 draft we're going to
realize potentially one of these teams
really cashed in this year
summarize the latest scandal with the
washington commanders
people could go to jail how about that
and it took a turn we've seen it unfold
over the past few days and i think one
of the realities is with the washington
commanders there's been this drip drip
drip for the past couple of years
and nothing ever happens so we think
that each new story is just another drip
that's not going to cause anything to
happen yesterday was different yesterday
was a congressional committee referring
to a federal agency with copies to the
attorneys general from three states with
jurisdiction over the washington
commanders
claims that
the organization engaged in two types of
financial fraud one
that the team shorted revenue that
should have gone to the league for
distribution to all teams that's
troubling and again these are
allegations but they're made by somebody
who worked for the team for 24 years the
other allegation which could result in
criminal prosecution the idea that they
had a deliberate scam in place again
allegedly i'm not looking to get sued
today or any day for that matter but the
notion that they were keeping
security deposits made by their best
customers the people who bought season
tickets year in and year out no matter
how crappy the team was they kept coming
back and there was supposedly some sort
of a scam to keep their security
deposits to make it very difficult to
get them back so people just say
screw it i'm gonna quit trying
that to me is the thing that could
launch a prosecution grand juries
indictments and you work your way up to
the ladder until you get to the very top
and all of a sudden daniel snyder's got
a lot more to worry about than losing
his team but they can't the government
can't force him to sell this would be
incumbent upon the owners and the
commissioner
yes okay at least 24 owners would be
required to force them to sell but i
think one of the reasons the league has
been reluctant
first of all the league doesn't want to
hold daniel snyder to a standard that
then would potentially apply to other
owners they're protecting the other
owners in protecting him but i think
they also don't want to get into a fight
with snyder because he will fight and
fight and fight and it will be ugly and
it will be nasty and there'll be dirty
laundry everywhere but
the league at this point may just
simply step back
let this thing play out
let's see if there's prosecution let's
see if there's pressure placed on daniel
snyder by others
to get out of this business that may be
the easiest path out of this for the nfl
and also dan from the league offices
perspective
i suspect some other owners are going to
be asking some tough questions about who
was minding the store here how
is it that snyder was able to pull this
off if it's true
if it's true that he was pushing money
from nfl events to other events at fedex
field and reducing the amount of money
they got properly shared with the nfl
there's an argument he made that someone
at the league office should have been
paying better attention to what was
going on and maybe figured this out
before it hit the fan he's mike florio
pro football talk live co-host and his
new book playmakers available online
wherever books are sold
bill belichick
turned 70.
now
he's as involved as any coach and you
start to look at when john wooden
stopped coaching or went red arbok when
he stopped coaching
like bill belichick this is now pete
carroll is at same age but it feels like
belichick is not reducing his workload
it feels like he's been all in
uh not a figurehead like paterno was or
bobby bowden was later in their careers
how do you explain this
well i mean the guy lives for football
he loves football it is his identity it
is what he does what else would he do
what would you retire and go do it's
where he gets his day in and day out
satisfaction two points dan a few years
ago robert kraft the owner of the
patriots told me at one of the league
meetings we had him on pft live he wants
bill belichick to keep coaching into his
80s he invoked names like rupert murdoch
and warren buffett people who have shown
that they can continue to function at a
high level beyond that 80th birthday but
here's the
the difference and this is why george
halas retired as coach of the bears in
the mid 60s he got to the point where he
just physically couldn't do it there's a
bad call he's got to run 20 yards to
yell at the official he can't do it
anymore he can't get there physically
that's the thing to watch as these
coaches get older and older can they
still
move on the sideline like they need to
to actively and properly coach the game
and the guy that i watch and this amazes
me i looked it up last week and i fell
out of my chair john harbaugh is 59
chuck noll retired at the age of 59 and
was never heard from again i think
harbaugh is going to be going 20 years
from now harbaugh at 70 is going to be
like a normal person at 50. he's the one
that i think is going to out coach all
of them and if anybody's got a chance to
do it into their 80s it's him
you were talking about the packers wide
receiver situation recently
um how are they addressing this to help
aaron rodgers after losing devonta adams
well rogers said after the loss to the
49ers he doesn't want to be part of a
rebuilding effort meanwhile his receiver
room has been blown
to smithereens when randall cobb is your
number one guy in 2022 you've got a
problem so what are they going to do dan
are they going to go after jarvis landry
or julio jones free agents that are
available maybe i don't know are they
going to try to trade for someone i
think they should try to trade for chase
claypool frankly because he doesn't need
to be paid right now and i don't think
he's going to be happy in pittsburgh
with mitchell trubisky as the starting
quarterback or do you draft someone do
you use a first round pick second round
pick and i think what they should do
they should involve aaron rodgers very
closely
in the scouting of these receivers he
made it clear that he resents the idea
that they just act like hey you just
work here we'll take care of the big
decisions get him involved have him
watch film get his input get him to buy
in to whoever it is they draft so he's
invested in getting that guy up to speed
they don't have a number one receiver
they won't have a number one receiver
unless they do something if they go the
route of the draft it's on rogers to
trust that guy quickly and if he's not
going to be there for the off-season
program that's his prerogative it puts
more pressure on everyone during
training camp to get that rookie if it
is a rookie that they go with up to
speed asafp and then what's happening
with the seahawks with
i i don't know if dk metcalf is
available
uh tyler lockett's available that that's
not gonna bode well for whoever's the
quarterback uh in seattle if you're
you're shopping those guys
once you trade russell wilson and
remember they said they had no intention
to trade russell wilson and then they
traded him so when they say they have
every intention of keeping dk metcalf i
assume that means he's out next too but
there's a fascinating dynamic in the nfl
right now
you've got teams that are willing to
give up major money and draft picks for
established receivers you've got other
teams that'll say
hey there's plenty of great receivers
coming out every year we'll take your
draft picks like the chiefs did we'll
take your draft picks we'll gladly
get rid of this burden of having to pay
tyree kill 27 28 million a year we'll
just start from scratch so where are the
seahawks right now as they're rebuilding
can you really get the most out of dk
metcalf
that's really the question and sims and
i talk about this all the time they
don't use him like they could like he
could be debo samuel in that offense the
guy's a superhero
but they they don't get the ball in his
hands as often as they need to so if
you're not going to use him trade him to
a team that will take the draft picks
and hope that you can you can create the
same magic you had 10 years ago when you
built through the draft and before you
know it you had a super bowl team yeah
that's why when the russell wilson
situation was ongoing and i had heard
they're they're privately quietly
shopping russell wilson so anytime pete
carroll would say no we have no
intention of uh trading and russ said
all the right things hey this is where i
want to be
meanwhile they were trying to see what's
the best deal they could get and they're
probably doing that with dk metcalf
right now
you have to because if you're not going
to pay him
and we see where the receiver market is
going and the longer you wait the more
expensive it's going to get if you're
not going to do it then why not make the
move now maximize your value and see
what happens now they reportedly aren't
listening but as we get closer to the
draft i think that's when the action may
happen and there are teams out there
that are willing to make that move give
up the picks give up the money to have
that high end receiver and the seahawks
are not in that mode right now they are
clearly in
tear it down and rebuild it so why not
get what you can
for a guy that you're not going to get
the most out of thank you mike great to
talk to you and congrats on the success
of playmakers thanks dan appreciate you
pal it's available wherever books are
sold and online